also bad is the rate at which the swamp
is being filled by the Donald Trump
administration it's being filled so fast
in fact that we can hardly keep up
clueless billionaire Education Secretary
Betsy DeVos has appointed the head of a
private student loan company to be in
charge of the federal government student
aid agency devices of course Donald
Trump's new Education Secretary she was
barely confirmed she's advocated for
defunding public schools in favor of
charter schools at her confirmation
hearing she was embarrassed by it was Al
Franken Tim Kaine Elizabeth Warren
Sanders Bernice goes on a hunt
pathetically embarrassing she also said
at those same confirmation hearings that
she wants guns in schools so that
grizzly bears can be shot her words not
mine and the Department of Education has
announced that Betsy DeVos appointed
Wayne Johnson to lead the office of
federal student aid not Dwayne the rock
Johnson okay but Pat was excited but I'm
talking about Wayne a Johnson this is an
appointment that doesn't require Senate
confirmation
the FSA administers about a trillion and
a half dollars in student loans for
forty two million borrowers as well as a
bunch of other aid programs and he is
the current CEO of a little old company
called reunion financial services
corporation this is a private student
loan company from which Johnson has
still not resigned his post the
Department of Education issued an
announcement about how he was appointed
it talks about how he's so qualified
blah blah blah blah blah but nowhere in
this statement that were showing you
does it mention that Johnson is the CEO
of this company but it makes sense that
they wouldn't want to mention it this is
called regulatory capture okay
regulatory capture is when in government
is basically a failure of government
when a regulatory agency that's there
supposedly to act in the interests of
the public at large ends up advancing
the interests of the commercial or
political concerns or those of interest
groups involved with that industry
rather than those of the public that it
is meant to serve
and when you have private industry
becoming the regulators its regulatory
capture it's bad it's really really that
but you know what they'll say on the
other side that these people have made
their money in their respective fields
perhaps screwing over the American
public but that's their fault another
going age down around woodwork on our
behalf because they just know how to
solve the problem who better to fix the
student loan problem than people who
know the student loan problem of course
the people who got rich from the student
loan problem are not necessarily the
people to fix the student loan problem
and they often leave with incredible
bonuses by the way Trump's Education
Secretary Betsy DeVos currently under
investigation by a congressionally
sanctioned watchdog group for statements
about refusing to enforce federal civil
rights in public schools I think that
this is going to not upset a lot of
Trumpets
you know why Pat because a lot of
Trumpets already see College as leftist
indoctrination to begin with so who
cares if it's not affordable and run by
private industry it's bad it's just
indoctrination I think they think that
it's just a safe space for liberal minds
to form not so much it's more about
critical thinking and that's why you see
as you become more educated you're most
likely to be on the left side of your
entire conception of this Oh colleges
liberal indoctrination thing it's got
causality backwards it ignores
common-sense I I don't even know how
else to say it but unfortunately like
with much of what's going on under the
Trump administration this is a disaster
that many Trump fists if they even hear
about it won't be concerned about it
because of their underlying politics and
beliefs in this case about the education
system